In which quadrant is the point
negative 7 comma 7 located?
So let's just review
what a quadrant is.
A quadrant are each
of the four sections
of the coordinate plane.
And when we talk
about the sections,
we're talking about the sections
as divided by the coordinate
axes.
So this right here is the
x-axis and this up-down axis
is the y-axis.
And you can see it
divides a coordinate plane
into four sections.
We call each of these
sections quadrants.
This one over here, where both
the x-values and the y-values
are positive, we call
the first quadrant.
And we use the Roman numeral I.
Then if we kind of
move counterclockwise
around the coordinate
plane, this quadrant where
the x-values are negative and
the y-values are positive,
we call this the
second quadrant.
I could write it.
We call this the
second quadrant.
Then we go down here where
both the x-values are negative
and the y-values are negative.
We call this the third
quadrant, once again
using Roman numerals.
Then finally the quadrant
where the x-values are positive
but the y-values
are negative, we
call this the fourth quadrant.
So let's see which quadrant
the point negative 7 comma
7 is located.
So there's two ways
to think about it.
You could just say, look,
we have a negative x-value.
Our x-value is
negative, so we're
going to move to the left.
So we're going to
be on this side.
We're going to be on
this side right here
of the coordinate plane.
Just by the fact that
the x-value is negative,
we're going to be either in the
second or the third quadrant.
Now, we know that the
y-value is positive.
We know that the
So if the x-value is negative
and the y-value is positive,
we're going to land
someplace right over here
in the second quadrant.
The other way to
think about it is you
could literally
just plot this point
and see that it falls
in the second quadrant.
So let's do that.
If x is negative 7.
So that's negative 1, negative
2, negative 3, negative 4,
negative 5, negative
6, negative 7.
Did I do that right?
1, 2, 3 4, 5, 6, 7.
So this is x is negative 7.
And then we have to
go up 7 because y
is equal to positive 7.
So 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 7.
So the point negative 7
comma 7 is right over here,
clearly lies in the
second quadrant.